YOU GET STARTED WITH YOUR IDEA.
CALL NOW. 807 100020. DOING
DECISIONS ON ONE OF THE MAIN
DRUGS USED IN MEDICATION
ABORTIONS. FIRST CAME THE RULING
BY A FEDERAL JUDGE IN TEXAS,
SCRAPPING FDA APPROVAL FOR THE
DRUG, MEDFORD CRESTONE. BUT LESS
THAN AN HOUR LATER, A FEDERAL
JUDGE IN WASHINGTON STATE RULED
TO PROTECT ACCESS TO THE DRUG
AND 17 DEMOCRATIC LED STATES AND
THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA. THOSE
TWO DECISIONS ARE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT ABORTION RULING
SINCE THE SUPREME COURT
OVERTURNED. ROE VERSUS WADE, AS
WE ALL REMEMBER LAST SUMMER, IT
SETS THE STAGE FOR ABORTION
RIGHTS TO BE A LEADING ISSUE IN
THE 2024 CAMPAIGN AND TALKING
ABOUT THIS MORE WITH US JOINING
US NOW CNN'S SENIOR POLITICAL
ANALYST JOHN AVALON, AND CNN
POLITICAL COMMENTATOR AND HOST
OF PBS FIRING LINE MARGARET
HOOVER. GUYS GREAT TO SEE YOU.
AS ALWAYS, WE APPRECIATE IT. UM
JOHN, YOU KNOW THIS ISSUE REALLY
MOTIVATED DEMOCRATIC VOTERS AND
2022. BUT IT SEEMS TO BE A
BATTLE THAT A LOT OF
CONSERVATIVES WANT TO KEEP
HAVING EVEN THOUGH IT MIGHT NOT
BE THE BEST THING FOR THEIR OWN
POLITICAL HEALTH. WHAT DO YOU
THINK? UM I THINK THE MESSAGE TO
VOTERS KEEP SEEMING TO SEND AS
IT'S THE EXTREMISM. STUPID I
MEAN, YOU KNOW, THIS IS
REPUBLICANS HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
WIN FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE AND
REMOVING A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
TO AN ABORTION. BUT MOST VOTERS
LOOK AT THIS AND SAY 7% OF
AMERICANS BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE
SAFE, LEGAL AND RARE, BASICALLY
IN LINE WITH THE PREVIOUS STATUS
QUO. UH UM AND YET TAKING THE
WIND. THEY THEY'RE JUDGES KEEP,
YOU KNOW, TAKING DOWN AN
ABORTION PILLS PUSHING FOR A
NATIONAL BAN ON ABORTION. THAT'S
THE POSITION THAT SOME
MAXIMALIST IN THE SENATE HAVE
TAKEN SOME PEOPLE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT, AND SO THERE'S A
SENSE THAT THIS GOES AGAINST
COMMON SENSE AND INDIVIDUAL
FREEDOM AND FUNDAMENTAL WAY
WHERE PEOPLE FEEL RIGHT HAS BEEN
TAKEN AWAY. SO AS LONG AS AS
REPUBLICANS KEEP PUSHING FOR A
MAXIMALIST POSITION, YOU'RE
GONNA SEE A PUSHBACK FROM FOLKS
WHO HAD PREVIOUSLY BEEN SOUND ON
THE ISSUE BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT
IT WAS SOME LAW, WHICH IT WAS
UNTIL THREE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES REVERSE THEMSELVES.
YEAH MARGARET, I MEAN, LAST
YEAR, IT WAS DESCRIBED AS THE
DOG CATCHING THE CAR, BUT IT'S
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY WANT TO KEEP
CATCHING THE CAR. JIM THERE IS
NO ISSUE. AH! I THINK EVEN
DONALD TRUMP WHERE REPUBLICANS
ARE MORE IN DENIAL ABOUT THE
NEGATIVE EFFECTS THIS IS HAVING
ON THE PARTY AND THEIR VIABILITY
TO WIN ELECTIONS AT THE STATE
LEVEL AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL. I
MEAN THIS ISSUE WHEN, WHEN ROE
V. WADE WAS OVERTURNED, FOR
EXAMPLE, AND WE WENT ON TO SEE
REALLY THE BLOODLETTING OF THE
2000 TO 2022 FALL ELECTION CYCLE
RESULTS, WHICH SHOULD HAVE BEEN
A TIDAL WAVE. OF REPUBLICANS
INTO THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES AND TURNED INTO
WHAT BECAME FIVE NOT A SINGLE
EDITORIAL, CONSERVATIVE
EDITORIAL PAGE, NOT A SINGLE
CONSERVATIVE COMMENTATOR WAS
ABLE TO ADMIT OR RECOGNIZE THAT
AND WE HAVE NOW DATA TO PROVE
THAT IT WAS THE ROE V. WADE
OVERTURNED. IT WAS THE DOBBS
DECISION THAT OVERWHELMINGLY
IMPACTED THE WOMEN COMING TO
POLLS. SUBURBAN WOMEN COMING AND
THERE ARE SOME REPUBLICANS WHO
ARE WILLING TO RECOGNIZE THAT
PUBLICLY VERY FEW. UH
REPRESENTATIVE NANCY MATES FROM
SOUTH CAROLINA, FOR EXAMPLE, OR
A PRO LIFE REPUBLICAN WHO'S
WILLING TO SAY THIS POSITION IS
KILLING THE PARTY. BUT THERE'S A
STRANGLEHOLD ON THE PARTY WITH
THIS ONE IS WITH THIS ONE ISSUE
. THE SPECIAL INTERESTS SIMPLY
CANNOT LET GO OF ITS CHOKEHOLD,
AND THAT'S REPUBLICAN ARE GONNA
KEEP LOSING IF THEY'RE NOT ABLE
TO MEET THE COUNTRY WHERE IT IS
IN THE SHOP. PISCES PEOPLE OFF
ABOUT POLITICS. YEAH YEAH. YEAH
AND JOHN. I MEAN, SPEAKING OF
THAT IN A DIFFERENT STATE AND
TENNESSEE THE DECISION TO EXPEL
THOSE TWO YOUNG BLACK LAWMAKERS
ARE TAKING PART IN A PROTEST
OVER GUN REGULATIONS. GUN REFORM
REPRESENTATIVE GLORIA JOHNSON,
WHO WAS WHITE. SHE SURVIVED
EXPULSION. BY ONE VOTE. I TRIED
TO ASK FELLOW DEMOCRATIC
LAWMAKER EARLIER THIS HOUR ABOUT
THIS. HE DIDN'T WANT TO GO DOWN
THAT ROAD AND SAY, WELL, IT WAS
BECAUSE OF RACE THAT THESE TWO
WERE EXPELLED WHILE SHE WAS NOT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK? I MEAN, IT
JUST DOESN'T IT CERTAINLY FEELS
LIKE THAT. IT'S CERTAINLY PLAYED
A ROLE IN IT PLAYED A PART IN
IT. I MEAN, HOW CAN YOU DENY IT?
BUT THAT'S WHAT SHE SAID ON CNN
THE OTHER NIGHT. YEAH SO YOU
KNOW, I'LL TAKE HER WORD FOR IT
. UM, BUT AGAIN, IT'S AN EXAMPLE
OF SELF DEFEATING POLITICS, UM,
ON REPUBLICANS PART WHERE THEY
ELEVATED THESE TWO YOUNG MEN
WILL PROBABLY BE PUT BACK IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE. THERE'S A
REASONABLE GOOD CHANCE FOR THAT.
BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT THIS.
CREEPING FRUSTRATED RELUCTANCE
TO EMBRACE REPRESENTATIVE
DEMOCRACY. I MEAN, YOU'VE GOT
YOU KNOW, IN A CITY IN A TOWN IN
THE STATE REELING IN THE WAKE OF
A HORRIFIC MASS SHOOTING AT A
SCHOOL AND INSTEAD OF TAKING ANY
ACTION AT ALL, THEY TRY TO
PUNISH THE LAWMAKERS WHO WERE
PROTESTING WITH PEOPLE OUTSIDE.
THAT'S ABOUT SHUTTING DOWN
DEBATE NOT BEING RESPONSIVE TO
PEOPLE'S NEEDS AND FOR A PARTY
THAT'S GOING TO WRAP ITSELF IN
THE CONSTITUTION, THE
CONSTITUTION AND LEGISLATIVE
BRANCHES AS DESIGNED BY THE
FOUNDERS ARE BY DEFINITION
DESIGNED FOR THE PROCESS OF
BARGAINING AND NEGOTIATION FOR
HAVING AN OPINION AND HAVING
THAT OPINION REFUTED THESE
LAWMAKERS. SPOKE THEIR MIND HOW
TO PEACEABLE PROTESTS PEACEABLY
ASSEMBLED AS THE FIRST AMENDMENT
SAYS THAT YOU CAN AND THEIR
SPEECH WAS SHUT DOWN. THEY WERE
PUNISHED FOR IT. NOT THAT IS NOT
HOW THE CONSTITUTION IS SUPPOSED
TO WORK, AND IT'S NOT A FREE
SPEECH ISSUE. OKAY, JUST
CHECKING LIKE COUNCIL CULTURE,
BUT TO THE EXTREME. AND I AM
SORRY. I MEAN, I JUST ONLY
BECAUSE IF I DON'T WORK IN THE
EMOTIONS WERE SO RAW EMOTIONS
WERE SO WRONG NASHVILLE. I MEAN
, IT'S I MEAN, ONE WOULD THINK
IT WOULD BE EASY TO UNDERSTAND
WHY SOME FOLKS WOULD WANT TO
PROTEST AND SOME STATE LAWMAKERS
MIGHT WANT TO JOIN THOSE
PROTESTERS. I MEAN THAT TO ME. I
THINK I KIND OF GOT LOST IN THIS
WHOLE THING IS THIS TERRIBLE,
TERRIBLE, AWFUL TRAGEDY THAT
TOOK PLACE IN NASHVILLE. OF
COURSE, PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
FIRED UP ABOUT THAT SORT OF
THING. BUT I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT ONE MORE THING, GUYS, AND
THAT IS I MEAN, THERE'S SO MUCH
THAT HAS HAPPENED SINCE LAST
TUESDAY. IT FEELS LIKE MAYBE A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO. BUT IT WAS
JUST A SEVERAL DAYS AGO THAT
DONALD TRUMP BECAME THE FIRST
CURRENT OR PAST PRESIDENT TO BE
INDICTED. IN A RAIN AND I JUST
WONDER. DOESN'T THIS CONTINUE TO
BE GOOD FOR TRUMP IN THE PARTY
AND THE REPUBLICAN PARTY BUT
TERRIBLE IN THE GENERAL
ELECTION? WELL IT IS LIKE I SAW
MY HUSBAND. I'M DOING A SIDE EYE
RIGHT HERE BECAUSE I SAW HIM
MAKE UP FIGHT. THE TRUTH IS,
YOU'RE RIGHT, JIM. THIS IS GOOD
FOR TRUMP IN THE PARTY, IT HAS
SOLIDIFIED HIS FRONT RUNNER
STATUS. THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINATION RIGHT AT THE MOMENT.
I MEAN, THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENED.
THESE ARE $7 MILLION IN THE LAST
WEEK. 25% AT LEAST OF THOSE
DOLLARS ARE NEW DOLLARS AND THE
BASE OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
SEEMS TO REALLY BE RALLYING
AROUND HIM AND UM, DOING AN US
AGAINST THEM. YOU KNOW, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE RULE OF
LAW AGAINST TRUMP. IT'S A
BIZARRE TURN OF EVENTS, BUT IT'S
REAL. YEAH, IT'S A REACTION.
IT'S A REACTION. LET'S BE REAL
ABOUT THAT. AND TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT, UM, YOU KNOW, TRUMP'S
RESURGENCE BEING, YOU KNOW A
POISON PILL FOR A GENERAL
ELECTION. WHAT? CNN'S NEW POLL
SHOWING ONLY 26% OF INDEPENDENT
VOTERS SUPPORT APPROVAL OF
DONALD TRUMP OVER 60% THOUGHT AN
INDICTMENT WAS JUSTIFIED. ONLY
8% SAID IT WAS HAD HAD NO MERIT
AT ALL THOSE INDEPENDENT VOTERS
WHO END UP MAKING THE DECISIONS
IN GENERAL ELECTIONS. SO YOU
KNOW THE PARTY? YOU KNOW, HE MAY
THRIVE ON THE OXYGEN OF
ATTENTION. BUT IF THAT MOTH
KEEPS GOING TO THAT CLAIM, IT'S
GOING TO BE BURNT TO A CRISP.
RIGHT AND WITH OTHER POTENTIAL
INDICTMENTS COMING OTHER TRIALS
POTENTIALLY COMING DOWN THE
PIKE. I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT THE
NUMBERS YOU JUST MENTIONED JOHN
HEADING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
FOR TRUMP AND THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY WH